[Music]  in this curious lagoon the rivers may  run red  but rest assured it's water not blood  although you could be forgiven for  confusing the  two the red lagoon is located 12 000  feet above sea level in an area of chile  so remote that it wasn't even known by  the national tourism office until 2009  and maybe that's a good thing  because much like the pyramids in egypt  the lagoon is believed to be cursed  legend says that the waters are owned by  the devil himself and he is responsible  for the mysterious disappearances that  have occurred along the shores  the thermal temperatures of the water at  100 to 120 degrees stop even wild  animals from approaching it  devils aside what causes this blood red  water well biologists studying the  lagoon recently traced it to algae  growing in the depths of the lake  still  much of this lagoon remains a mystery  a visit to this place is a reminder  there is still much to marvel at on this  planet  [Music]  you